I'm sorry I was put on the pedestal
growing up you were I mean even I was a
ward of the state but because of my um
my
intelligence and um my skills my talents
and stuff like that um I was given a lot
of recognition from like you know judges
and the people in the courts and stuff
like that because most of my time was
spent between there and college you got
special treatment you think I know I did
I know I did it made it kind of hard at
some of them home cuz you know you got
to go back to you know the unit with
those people and live with them and i'
like to think that I never took the um
the gifts given me and U made anybody
feel less than I would always make a
point to you know point out my other you
know like school friends for answers and
stuff don't just pick out me you know I
was probably supposed to be like the
most successful person in the world
based on everything that was given to me
um can I get you to pull your hair off
your face yeah
nothing really
happened um we were getting we were
being mistreated at home really really
badly me and my two other siblings I was
a middle
child um by the age of five my mother
was uh selling Us in order to do drugs
herself and um so you're original your
biological parents my biological mother
we were taken away from when we were
barely even two and my other sister
would have been five six at the time
what happened there because she was
neglecting us which is uh which is why I
was deaf at the time as well it was
medical neglect so I went through this
foster home with these people adopted me
for about 3 four years before anybody
figured out that I was actually deaf and
not
stupid it's um it was kind of cool um I
still know sound language so you're
hearing came
back I I had to have tubes put in my
ears twice surgery and everything oh
really yeah well because I wasn't born
that way you know what I'm saying I was
sick and just nobody had known it so
that was kind of different so back to
your second adopted family um so that
adopted family they were she was rotten
after she had um after she had divorced
their adopted father I mean she was just
a whole different person and uh we were
made to stay with her
and uh my sister started running away
and things were really bad and we
couldn't do nothing about it none of it
you know I remember the police showing
up at the house a couple times telling
you know because the neighbors had
called because of screaming and stuff
and I remember being black and blue one
time and the cop telling my parents just
not to leave him a mark next time and
walked out of the
house
um my sister ran away two days before um
Easter and uh on Easter morning the
police came to tell us that that the
house bur down that morning had um been
due to um her body being set on
fire U one of the men that my mom was
allowing to come into the house had
taken her to an abandoned house and
raped her and uh he's a Spanish to kill
her and then he set her on
fire um that was lifechanging for me I
went from being the how old was she she
was
12 unfortunately she was every
pedophiled dreamed come true because she
was Native American and white so by the
time that she was 12 she was carrying
her own Double D the first newspaper
clipping said a body of a 20 to 30y old
woman had been
found
no
um I went from being that quiet kid that
caused no problems because you know the
hearing made me a mark in the house with
everybody I was easy picking
to somebody totally different after
that and I got put in the system I my
mother came to a school one day and told
us that she was pregnant with her own
kids and uh my idea was that you going
to replace my sister and you're going to
hurt these kids too and uh I snapped I
took a m little baseball bat so this is
your third set of parents she said this
is this is the adopted parents they
never they they never changed she never
she was never removed from us you you
told me they were selling you um she did
yeah she was like for her drug habit she
was allowing men to come in and do
things to us I remember the first
time she's never she was never charged I
didn't tell anybody until I was 16 you
know I didn't know what to say but
um by the time everything had exploded
at the house with her news of having a
Bab babies I was being carded off to um
a volleyball camp at the University of
Illinois in Champagne Illinois I'd been
one of 10 girls that had been um picked
to go to summer camp there with all the
players uh unfortunately then last I got
into a fight with a girl over um a
checkbook that somebody had given me and
wasn't there to give it to me a girl
made a comment about my sister being
killed and that pushed her out the
window and so my mother came and get me
they adopted mother she came to come get
me that night and instead of taking me
home she took me to the hospital and uh
I never went back to her house ever
again in my life so you you grew up in
what what city DCFS from 9 to 18 in the
state of Illinois no you grew up in
Tennessee Tennessee is home for us um
when we got to have the in between
breaks with Dad and her we go back to
Tennessee but she's the one that moved
us to uh Illinois oh I see so I went I
went back home year later to Southern
Illinois B back home to Tennessee no but
Southern Illinois uh with her yeah it's
like Central it's like Central Illinois
and well I ended up in the system after
that part where
um Mark I was in 136 homes in a year in
one year's time
period it's like the system was moving
me to keep me from somebody or something
I don't understand I was always praised
for being very intelligent I was always
you know put up on you know GL Bor
because of all my abilities you know how
triculate I am and just all of that I
always kind of felt like
um unrealistic like these people didn't
really see me you know because of all
that I was a I was attending the U ofi
at the age of 14 because I won a essay
contest with a school science project
that I didn't know was being
submitted so I didn't even get to have
the real college experience DCFS came to
my classes with me you know and stuff
like that and I still went back to the
children's home at night you know but um
most of my life I lived out of a bag I
didn't really talk to people because I
was moved around so much and
because I got to the point where telling
my story and what was happening to us
was just it didn't affect me in the
least anymore you know I could turn
things off and uh I was dealing with so
much in all these homes I've been locked
in
cages I've been
starved but um I've thought I mean
literally had to go into the basement
and fight other student other you
know other foster kids you know
um I remember being locked under the
stairs for a period of
time
I I remember at 13 the doctor saying I
was the making of a mass
murder because of everything that was
going on and because how quiet I was but
how intelligent I
was and as a kid you you you Revel in
that the anger because everybody left me
you know I have my bi family and I have
adopted family
and no matter what none of them ever
came to find me in the system they just
left me be and all this other stuff was
happening and nobody gave a [__] so you
know I was pretty pissed
off pretty hateful
myself you know God couldn't love me and
nobody else
dared um everything kept happening at
all these
homes you know something good come and
then like bad things would just knock it
all away you
know um I got close to a lot of girls
that would you know confide in
me and then like all of a sudden Jean's
running away and we find out after a
month that she's been raped inside and
out with a knife and lives the mon to
tell who her killer is and leaves with
me a note I'm 12 years old at the time
this stuff was
Unreal and I still only did weed cuz
when I would run away from the
children's home I would always end up
like finding the people in the hood and
stuff like that and I'm the white girl I
have braces and everything back then
glasses and stuff so you know people
were always checking my hair and
wondering you know whether or not it was
real and
um I wonder sometimes myself
cuz I put myself in a lot of bad
positions just to try and get hurt so I
wouldn't be here no
more and
uh I can tell you all the things that
happened in all those times I remember
an encounter with a staff member a head
staff member of a children show I was
having a sexual relationship with him
for a period of
time very interesting I grew up really
fast and
um
very kind of mean after a while you know
I got into martial arts I was very
athletic um I anything that was a
challenge I was in it you know not just
you know intellectually but
physically and uh start fighting
and getting myself in trouble that way
right how old are you now I'm 39 you're
39 mhm I'm not the same woman today as I
was back then by any
means I
struggle where have you spent your 20s
and
30s um my so I have traveled to more
than 38
States I would consider myself free
spirited and a Wanderer all those that
wander are not lost though okay I don't
I'm not comfortable sitting
still all those years with my husband I
did we had a home out there in the
southern Illinois and then when he got
sick we moved up to
Chicago that was an
experience I don't really get into drugs
or nothing though you know I think like
my way of Ting I was a
cutter I was a sell farmer I didn't um I
gotten to a point in my life by that you
know period of time where I wanted to
spread the goodness I seen how bad the
world was and I was kind of Ni naive to
[__] very naive to everything CU you
know I used to think that the real world
was out here in consideration you know
how I was growing up but I never really
had the the full depth of just how how
different because I didn't have that
communication with people I didn't have
a bond with people I don't understand
how Society worked I don't have the
politics of everything I just kind of
a a mute for say but when did your
hearing
come um the surgery happened by the age
of by the time I was about four or five
we got the surgeries completed to where
I could hear again it took two of them
and so I went I went for about that many
years in life without which was it was
neat because I know sign language from
it you
know but um 20s and 30s I was really I
was not doing good you know I when I got
emancipated from the system before I met
my husband I was in just I didn't know
how to survive out here I didn't know
how to be around people I didn't know
how to you know form relationships with
people and I was still very hurt and
upset by my family who was in the same
town that I was in but had no
communication with me at all like I
didn't
exist I always wonder what I done to
deserve that because
uh I didn't
um my sister and I I have a little
sister that they raised you know that
was my biological she I don't get along
at all because of everything that you
know I endured through those years and
um I tried so hard in my early 20s I
tried so hard to build a relationship
with her which was why some that
traveling was happening you know that
way we could experience things together
and she could see that life wasn't just
like one horse town you know like they
grew up in you know a couple little
towns and that was the most they ever
moved in their life hell I couldn't
unpack my house after I got married for
a year and a half because I wasn't sure
if it was going to be there tomorrow and
based on I grew up and so that was
really odd um an odd relationship for me
to try
and fix I guess you could
say the judge was my
father the judge was my father and his
the stenographer lady she was like my
big sister and the mentor I had was a
previous therapist that um very well
known um she beautiful woman that was
more of a mother to me than anybody in
my
life I had some really good influences
thank the Lord
because after um those first years you
know traveling around and stuff in my
20s I hit a couple of bumps and I really
needed some kind of guidance
and
um it wasn't all that great I got put in
prison I got put in prison for defending
myself the D told me I use excessive
force I took a baseball bat to a guy
elbows and knees cat his
knees he been molesting his sons for
years
turned him out so after everything that
he' been doing and all the things he'd
been saying to me for all that time I
kind of felt like you know when the day
came that he actually tried to force
himself on me I was
prepared after that I got the smarts
because you know you get into prison and
you meet all these people that you know
are very intelligent very
talented and you start figuring out
other stupid things to do
and I didn't feel like I ever had
anybody that I had to answer to nobody
gave a [__] about
me and so disappointments and stuff like
that didn't mean nothing that didn't
register with
me
so I heard people a lot tell my husband
tell me my
husband
but
James and I met when I was on
a I was supposed to go to a
party for the weekend with some friends
and instead it ended up being somebody's
family reunion they totally blew me so
after I you know played my role was
polite to his own
entire family because I was so far from
home told him leave me alone I ended up
talking to the guy at the bar I married
that man three weeks later he was 20
years older than me I was 19 he was a
bachelor at
39 eight and a half years together until
uh thosis of the the liver took
him how many kids do you
have I've had seven I have five now I've
lost
two that's why I'm out here that's how I
ended up in
California I um I got to find um have a
relationship with um two of my sons that
have been adopted years after I got out
of um DCFS I've never been able to keep
my kids they've always taken them from
me because of drugs no because of my own
history with
them you know I'd have the jobs I'd have
everything in a row I just never good
enough how' you lose two of your
kids um well one of them would have
killed me if I would taken all away and
so they took him
out mon sorry what happened baby was I
was going to bleed out with the baby so
they took about 8 months inside me that
was crazy and my my son my 16-year-old
son
um he just killed
himself
um been a year now don't feel like no
here who's
autistic
I remember the day that my sister showed
up I knew something was wrong cuz I
don't talk to her at all I don't I don't
even know that
sister I'm tell you the day that they
she told me it was him that was
gone I lost my mind I you know autistic
kids they don't really do stuff like
that I didn't know that you know and
then back in my head I had a fight
with you know wondering if it was true
or if they done if they' done it to him
his adopted parents who were my my
adopted father's sister and
husband
um let see my
dragu was limited into marijuana growing
up for the most part because I used to
transport I used to cook dope make salad
and everything else but me and my
girlfriend we used to transport between
Illinois in
Tennessee crack and weed and stuff so I
knew the dangers of all that stuff I was
kind of you know epy about it never was
into pills because I'm more of a
spiritual medicinal herbal
St but because of all the issues I'd had
growing up and all the abuse I made made
a crazy decision to
try a sex site
online and meet up with a guy for some
light
BDSM only to find out a month after we
started meeting up with each other that
he was in fact bangging me in the neck
with meth when he was choking me out so
the reason when work on my girlfriend
when I got home was because I didn't
have the right stuff and from there I
did research to shoot
myself and continued
a pretty crazy drug
habit especially the meth of you
know
um is that what you're using
now
actually I'm clean for a
week I shot myself in the foot because I
ain't got nowhere else to shoot the
doctors did all that believe it or
not but I myself didn't have nowhere
else to shoot and tried to shoot myself
in the foot and I got
cellulitis cellulitis end up in the
hospital how you like
that crazy it's so clean for a
week I'm not going to use a needle over
again that's enough to wake me up I
[Music]
like I like the effects of the drug
because it allows me to be uninhibited
and deal with the things but I've kind
of found out here recently that Sherm is
awesome and I look at myself and I'm
like how the hell did I get to where I
am today how did I go from all that with
all those good people in my life to this
what's going
on you come out here you get your [__]
stolen and don't have it once or twice
because no you're just stupid and you
people are like that back
home so then you gotta wait and do
everything from a far distance and
you're struck cuz you can't do [__] cuz
you're sitting around waiting on
documents
right somehow or another that led me to
a bottle of
shum but I don't know about the the
natural effect of it CU obviously like
like baling fluid isn't it I don't know
I know this much is helped a lot with
the healing of my son that sounds crazy
doesn't
it the four times that I've done
it I've um the experiences that I got to
have with people and the conversations
really kind of brought to light some of
my stuff in
life and
U wake me up a little bit I know it's
time to go back home I got other kids
waiting on me to get you know myself
back together where are you staying
now I jump around a little bit I don't
too well get along with people out here
cuz
uh I'm not selling my
body I always have what I need if I
don't I go
without and then whatever else people
use me to
[__] few their gos or whatever else I
get tossed to the best that much in my
life I don't care like can't do any harm
to me I've really literally learned
young that y'all don't matter it's me
against the world you
know I think the only thing that's
thrown me off Mark being out this way
besides the fact that people are hateful
and judgmental and so
rude have been the
stalkers stalkers are the crazy ones
that makes you have my anxiety so bad
bad I can't get stuff done
sometimes you don't know if somebody's
going to come snatch you up or you know
why the hell are y'all watching
me and my life is crazy so if you're
just following me around doing me all
the time you just as crazy as
me so
serious what's your biggest fear
now I'm not gonna make it out of here
alive I've um I had death threats and
stuff happen out here just because um I
don't know I don't know like I said I
don't know the politics of the cities
and the streets and stuff like that I
barely know it and you know just a get
by in my
life but um out here I'm a real no no I
don't understand why people feel the
need to wake up every day and go hey I
got to make money let's go chase it's a
dollar well if I were back home I'd be
on the farm and I would I mean between
the animals and what they provide and
all the you know the gardens and stuff
that's work and you get paid and you get
to sit around and you get to enjoy it
so it's fast-paced living ain't really
all all is cut out to be for
me I have a weird habit too I'm uh I
like the night times because it's
peaceful and I ain't got no fear there's
not a man out here that's going to put
fear in my heart because of everything
that I went through as a kid growing up
I'm going walk the streets I'm going
ride my bike around I don't give a [__]
if you threaten to kill me cuz U you can
get it back I promise you that you know
after a while you respond to these
people but I I'm not going to stop I
walk around and wander because that's my
you know I'm just getting [__] out of my
brain and it's peaceful for me and it's
like the
danger hell I'll be more scared of
myself the day that I finally snap Mark
cuz I ain't done it since my son
died I haven't let it all out not once I
hate to be the [__] that it does
happened to finally though I'm telling
you that I'm brutal when it comes to
just you know a face to face
confrontation because I'm
truthful you
know it's
kind Christine what what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your
life Mark I teach my kids this every day
too that kindness is strength and that's
why I say
this when I left the Chism homes and all
those experiences I had a chip on my
shoulder and you couldn't look at me you
know without me just
being with the healing that I I had with
my husband's relationship and you know
learning stuff as I went with him I
realized you know
that I didn't never want to make people
feel the way that I was made feel
because that wasn't right and that's my
goal in life I almost read you know I'm
a
Cheerleader you know I would rather pick
you up and you know put you toward your
goals and you know motivate you every
day to do something like that then to
see you know you down and feel like crap
and everybody just [__] on each
other and
uh um I would definitely say that you
know be mindful of the people you
know be mindful of yourself and the
people around you these days more so
than anything just be
safe be safe on a spiritual
level cuz I think this experience opened
my eyes to the reality
of where we're at in today's world for
real and just be kind to each
other cuz we we meant to love each other
everybody is like hating because you're
different and it's like you're supposed
to embrace that we were never intended
to be like each
other you know there's beauty in all
that it's sad people can't see it
all right Christine yeah thank you so
much for sharing your
story I wish you lots of luck out
here